knowing what you know about what makes
valuable companies and what builds
wealth what are some businesses that
you'd want to start right now and what
would you optimize for and what metrics
would you try to optimize for and how
yeah I mean I think it depends on what
you're what you're trying to optimize
for if you're just trying to I'm asking
you well I'm asking you for me
personally I mean I I really find value
in balancing home life and work right so
family is super important to me so my
answer is probably a little bit
different for me and I want to live not
a big city and so that's great I want to
hear what you would do yeah yeah so if I
was starting over today I would probably
start something in the construction
space or home services space maybe
office services I want to get in
something that's it's I like competing
in areas where there's not a natural
selection of people into that right so
you don't want to be in the winery
business because everyone in Silicon
Valley who exits
a business goes and buys a winery right
and pumps a bunch money into it like I
don't I don't want to be in the film
business because everybody who you know
every son of a billionaire you know
makes movies you know owning restaurants
is really difficult I mean separate from
all the stuff we're going to hear now
because everyone you know that makes me
money thinks it'd be easy and once they
own their own restaurant so I like two
things that sort of have a natural
selection biased against them like
nobody drives by somebody building a
swimming pool in Arizona in the summer
and says you know what I really want to
quit my job in the air conditioning and
go dig a hole in the ground right so we
want to get involved in things like that
I would try to take something probably
that that is small and partner with them
that they already have the
infrastructure in place the sort of the
the technical side and the systems there
and then I would really try to spend
some time you know how can we use you
know latest technology to make us more
efficient try to build something that's
scalable
sort of beyond a geography and get a
model down a billing model a sales model
down that we thought was replicatable
and that really had some sort of mode
around it and then I would try to scale
it over time and I
specifically yeah anything specifically
I think would depend on largely on what
I could find in the geography I mean
here in Columbia I mean there's there's
a fantastic HVAC service company that's
still fairly small but they've got great
systems they actually develop their own
software be something like that that I'd
want to partner with and say okay look
look you know I want to get my hands
dirty and get involved in I mean I'm uh
I'm not an investor by heart like my I
mean I'm an entrepreneur that's what I
love to do and that's how we think about
our business is being operators and
entrepreneurs and so I I wouldn't
necessarily get involved in finance I
mean finance to me is a mechanism that
allows and enables entrepreneurship and
and you know running real companies it's
not trading paper back and forth so I
would probably get far more involved in
in sort of non tech entrepreneurship
which I know you guys are in Silicon
Valley and this can fall on deaf ears no
III like I like what you're saying but
you you so you said HVAC you said each
bag weighs yeah pools lawn service I
think I service yeah like lot like lawn
and garden care type stuff I mean have
you ever tried to get somebody call you
back it's yeah you want to hear
something cool we had a so Brian you
know who Brian Scudamore is no just got
a more 1-800 jump oh yeah yeah okay so
the guy own is the guy who owns his
name's Brian he's Canadian he's friends
with me and Sean I shoot the with
him every once in a while it's like a
what is that Sean like a 500 million
dollar a year company he owns all of it
and he we either me or some one of us
asked him where opportunity is he goes
man if I don't do the same thing I would
do money hundred got junk but I would do
it from lawn care or for irrigation yeah
yeah that's times up I'm talking about
yeah I mean there's there's all these
like strange
I mean niches that you can get into and
I would do is probably take my time and
go and talk to a lot of people who are
already in business and say what is your
biggest problem like who's the supplier
that you're most annoyed with you know
what's the customer that you have that's
just killing it that type of thing and I
probably go try to snake my way into one
of those one of those businesses and
then just it's really just about getting
a foothold right and that's what you
need is you need a foothold and then you
can start building on it from there but
I mean that the problem is if you've got
a if you've got a boat that you're
trying to row that's rickety and and it
may look
on the outside but it's just not gonna
go anywhere it doesn't matter how hard
you row it and I think that's a you know
early my career when I was involved and
you know more the agency business that's
how I felt it was felt like I mean I
could just rode that thing as hard as I
could and I maybe get an inch further
and that's why I just want to get out of
businesses there like that
[Music]